- [Instructor] So we are
interested in studying
the relationship between
the amount that folks study
for a test and their score on a test,
where the score is between zero and six.
And so what we're going to do is go look
at the people who took the test,
we're going to plot for each person
the amount that they
studied and their score,
so for example, this data point is someone
who studied an hour and
they got a one on the test,
and then we're going to
fit a regression line,
and this blue regression line
is the actual regression line
for these four data points.
And here is the equation
for that regression line.
Now there's a couple of
things to keep in mind.
Normally when you're doing
this type of analysis,
you would do it with far
more than four data points.
The reason why I kept this to four
is because we are actually
going to calculate
how good a fit this
regression line is by hand.
And typically, you
would not do it by hand.
We have computers for that.
Now, the way that we're going to measure
how good a fit this
regression line is to the data
has several names.
One name is the standard
deviation of the residuals.
Another name is the root
mean square deviation,
sometimes abbreviated RMSD.
Sometimes it's called
root mean square error.
So what we're going to do
is, is for every point,
we're going to calculate the residual,
and then we're going to square it,
and then we're gonna add up
the sum of those squared residuals.
So we're gonna take the
sum of the residuals,
residuals squared, and then
we're going to divide that
by the number of data
points we have minus two.
And we can talk in future videos,
or a more advanced statistics class,
of why you divide by two.
It's related to the idea that
what we're calculating here
is a statistic, and
we're trying to estimate
a true parameter as best as possible,
and n minus two actually
does the trick for us.
But to calculate the root
mean squared deviation,
we would then take a square root of this.
And some of you might
recognize strong parallels
between this and how we calculated
sample standard deviation
early in our statistics career,
and I encourage you to think about it.
But let's actually calculate it by hand,
as I mentioned earlier in this video,
to see how things actually play out.
So to do that, I'm going to give ourselves
a little table here, so let's
say that is our x value,
in that column, let's
make this our y value,
let's make this y-hat
which is going to be equal
to 2.5x minus two, and
then let's make this
the residual squared, which is going to be
our y value minus our y-hat value,
our actual minus our estimate
for that given x, squared,
and then we're going to sum them all up,
divide by n minus two,
and take the square root.
So first, let's do this data point.
So that's the point, one
comma one, one comma one.
Now what is the estimate
from our regression line?
Well, for that x value,
when x is equal to one,
it's gonna be 2.5 times one minus two.
So it's gonna be 2.5 times one minus two,
which is equal to 0.5, and
so our residual squared
is going to be one minus
0.5, one minus 0.5, squared,
which is equal to, that's
gonna be .5 squared,
which is going to be 0.25.
Alright, let's do the next data point.
We have this one right over here.
It is two comma two.
Now our estimate from the regression line,
when x equals two, is
going to be equal to 2.5
times our x value times two, minus two,
which is going to be equal to three.
And so, our residual
squared is going to be
two minus three, two minus three, squared,
which is negative one squared,
which is going to be equal to one.
Then we can go to this point.
So that's the point two
comma three, two comma three.
Now, our estimate from our regression line
is going to be 2.5 times
our x value, times two,
minus two, which is going
to be equal to three,
and so our residual here
is going to be zero,
and you can see that that point
sits on the regression line.
So it's going to be three
minus three, three minus three,
squared, which is equal to zero,
and then last but not least,
we have this point right over here.
When x is three, our y value,
this person studied three hours,
and they got a six on the
test, so y is equal to six,
and so our estimate from
the regression line,
you could say what you
would've expected to get
based on the regression line,
is 2.5 times our x value,
times three, minus two, is equal to 5.5.
And so our residual squared
is six minus 5.5 squared,
minus 5.5, squared, so it's
.5 squared, which is 0.25.
So now, the next step, let me take the sum
of all of these square
residuals, so this is,
let me just write it this way.
Should we just do it like this?
So the sum of the residuals,
residuals squared,
is equal to, if I just sum all of this up,
it's going to be point,
it's going to be 1.5.
1.5, and then if I divide
that by n minus two,
so if I divide by n minus two,
that's going to be equal to,
I have four data points,
so I'm gonna divide
by four minus two, so
I'm gonna divide by two,
and then I'm gonna want to
take the square root of that.
Then I'm gonna want to take
the square root of that,
and so this is going
to get us, 1.5 over two
is the same thing as 3/4, so
it's the square root of 3/4,
or the square root of three over two.
And you could use a calculator
to figure what that is,
to figure out what that is as a decimal,
but this gives us a
sense of how good a fit
this regression line is.
The closer this is to
zero, the better the fit
of the regression line.
The further away from zero, the worse fit.
And what would be the units
for the root mean square deviation?
Well, it would be in terms
of whatever your units are
for your y-axis; in this case,
it would be the score on the test.
And that's one of the other
values of this calculation,
of taking the square root
of the sum of the squares
of the residuals dividing by n minus two.